boa tarde
gostava de perguntar primeiro quem é que
alguma vez já fugido casa indicada
vamos falar com o senhor e fugir de casa
este genério siri fugi de casa e fui
para a grécia estive a trabalhar num
campo de refugiados efes os turnos da
noite e foram coisas muito distintas
na altura em que o convidaram para fazer
esta tese é shayk este tema é fugir de
casa este tipo seria uma coisa que eu ia
fazer uma coisa gira eu fugi de casa e
fui ter com aqueles que forçadamente
fogem de casa
acontece que na altura já foi a algum
tempo é estava como estresse na
faculdade e não queria pensar nisso
quanto rurais no fugir de casa e durante
esta preparação percebi que não era por
este caminho que criei não era sobre os
refugiados que eu vinha falar porque os
refugiados não são pessoas que precisam
de pena são pessoas do mundo e que como
eu vivem no mundo então vou falar da
minha casa e das razões que fizeram city
e fugir de minha casa três preciso falar
um queridinho
eu tenho 22 anos e são aproximadamente 8
mil dias aproximadamente
eu não fiz os cálculos exatos e durante
os 22 anos
eu cresci e vivi muitas coisas e wifi eu
sofri eu aprendi sobretudo vive tem seis
irmãos e que são melhor presente que os
meus pais eram de mim é fora de mim são
a sensação que tem que não estou sozinha
no mundo
sou dono da minha imagem e enfermagem
é não é uma licenciatura é uma maneira
de estar na vida enfermagem os meus
professores costumam dizer que não há
nada na imagem que aconteceu por acaso e
eu acredito nisto enfermagem é feita de
trigo nozes e olha para o detalhe da
atenção às coisas mais pequenas que nós
temos dentro de nós e uma impressão mas
que eu me interessei por roda e ser cor
de rosa
além de ser minha vida não é só uma
coisa é uma menina é uma filosofia de
vida é que o que eu gostava de ser é ser
curto rosa é ser certa na minha
circunstância de casa em casa na altura
e por duas razões primária turquia não
tem vergonha do mundo incrível acontecem
coisas mas eu faço parte e por isso que
a certeza na altura que cria as minhas
mãos com o trabalho que eu pudesse fazer
então todos os dias depois do estúdio
que fazia durante a noite quero é ver a
minha maior vontade de ir abraçar este
mundo outra vez estar com os refugiados
isso não é razão é porque sai que é
preciso fazer silêncio das minhas coisas
pequenas daquelas coisas que não gostam
de mim e às vezes é difícil fazer isso é
que com tantas coisas à nossa volta e
então eu sei que cada vez que faz
silêncio e descubro mais um querendo ir
e fui fui pra grécia estive lá durante o
imaginário fugir de casa
fugi de casa é minha casa
são essas coisas que vocês vêem aqui e
estas coisas são
dentro da minha casa
pensar e gosto de pensar que pedras no
caminho é termos todas um dia
construíram uma ponte até a céu e então
estas muitas pedras que eu vou
construindo diz que eu vou apanhar a
estes irmãos que têm esta imagem que
tenho em minha vida e se cor rosa que eu
gostava de ser enquanto em era isso que
eu queria dizer quando tem alguma dúvida
entre fazer ou não fazer estará não está
a dizer se a dizer não à pergunta que eu
faço pra mim é como é que eu posso ser
mais cor-de-rosa então essa é a resposta
que eu sei que é certo e essa aqui e ali
e fugir de casa é minha casa sou eu nem
minha circunstância e minha vida certa e
por que eu gosto de falar da minha casa
e vou fugir da minha casa na verdade eu
não fugi de casa e fui muito fiel à
minha casa porque eu sei aquilo em que
eu acredite eu sei que o que fui fazer
eu fugi da casa em que eu vivo mas a
minha casa sou eu é minha casa são estas
coisas que vocês vêem são aquilo que
vocês vêm à vossa frente eu sou é minha
casa e que o que eu procuro minha vida é
minha construção é apanhar jogos é por
cimento ea se alimentar estas coisas
todas
e lá dentro de janelas ser portas ter
tapetes e ter cobertores e convidar
ambiente e ter pessoas crianças e
pessoas que gostam de estar na minha
casa e isso é que o que eu quero para a
minha vida e é por isso que hoje que é
preciso fugir de casa para saber qual é
a nossa casa é preciso fazer silêncio
das nossas coisas pra receber quase que
são as coisas que pertencem à nossa casa
quase que são os quadros que o preciso
pôr na parede com a selecção os pessoas
que precisarem as pessoas que vai jantar
em minha casa e é esse minha casa
as crises dizer por último em que eu
gosto muito
sangue dia esforço da equipe vai encher
colocar mais fogo unidade e ônibus
fizerem hostil ao certo mas fique certo
com as coisas certas lá dentro a vossa
casa vai ser não só uma casa do mundo
mas uma casa é parou muito e do mundo e
no mundo ficará presente e prince
fugindo casa quando precisarem
reconstruir a nossa casa é minha
namorada é motivos alemã
obrigada